it's election season so listen up this
is the most important election in our
lifetime I mean definitely mine but
probably so many other people's as well
every single election is portrayed as
the most important election of all time
I will say for the 2018 midterm
elections it really is the most
important election of all time yes the
midterms they fall between every
presidential election and we got one
coming up the media generally portrays
the midterms as the day Americans have a
chance to send the guy in the White
House a message either this finger or
this finger but on November 6 there's so
much more you're voting for that affects
your everyday life more than any Russian
collusion or PP tape or the latest
dumbest tweet
I'm still on Cote say hey guys I'm Kate
and this Sunday I'm giving you a cheat
sheet on the various things you might be
voting for this November 6 from attorney
general to Senator to waterboard and why
the midterms matter so hit that
subscribe button and let's get into it
you've probably heard about the
so-called Blue Wave in which Democrats
are predicted to take back a bunch of
seats in the midterm elections because
President Trump is not a popular person
well there's no wave if there's no
voters and traditionally midterms are
where democracy goes to die in the last
midterm election in 2014 the u.s. had
the lowest voter turnout in seventy
years in fact look at this graph on
voting rates since 1990 these Peaks are
turnout rates during presidential
elections and these valleys are midterms
it's basically a doomsday graph in the
shape of Bart Simpson's haircut
coincidentally Bart Simpson probably
doesn't vote in the midterms even the
people that do vote tend to be older
whiter and Republican err and when it
comes to 2018 a recent survey found that
only 28% of young people said they would
certainly vote you guys when voter
turnout is low it just means that people
who don't have our same interests who
don't have our same agenda and who don't
have the same vision for our communities
are making decisions on your behalf
oh and don't forget everyone's ballot
out there is gonna be a little bit
different depending on where you live so
consider this video a primer for future
elections too okay let's start with your
national offices first the US House of
Representatives these are the people
that represent your congressional
district on Capitol Hill in November no
matter where you live you will be voting
on a US rep every single one of the 435
districts are up for a vote for
Democrats to win control of the house
only about two dozen need to flip and
these districts some say are on track to
do so so why should you care well the US
House of Representatives is the chamber
that begins impeachment proceedings but
more importantly the House passes
federal laws and for the last two years
Trump has had his way with a majority
Republican house so with a different
party in control than the president his
policy wish lists like tax reform and
military spending wouldn't necessarily
be an automatic pass and also whichever
party is in control sets the agenda well
there are so many laws so many easy laws
that our representatives in Congress can
pass and can put forth to be discussed
and debated the people that you decide
to put in Congress right now they're
gonna decide our lives for the next
however many years that they're in
office then we have senators 33 states
will be holding US Senate elections in
November and experts think that
Tennessee and Texas could elect their
first Democratic senators and decades
and that seats in Missouri and Florida
could flip to Republicans why does that
matter because senators also passed laws
and they are also the ones that confirm
nominees to the cabinet and the Supreme
Court they also deal with possible
impeachment proceedings cool so those
are the federal races and those are ones
that are covered a lot in the mainstream
media but the reality is these lawmakers
day to day actions don't usually affect
your day to day lives
that's where state officials come in
first you got your governors 36 states
will hold election for governors on
November 6th and whether it's union
busting in Wisconsin or slashing health
care in Iowa every state's election is
happening on the backdrop of some pretty
important issues here in the state of
California currently you have two
candidates one Democrat one Republican
who have opposing views on immigration
and if you look at what happened in
California over the last couple of years
you know we were the states that
provided the driver's licenses to
undocumented immigrants we Ross to the
state that provided in-state tuition for
undocumented residents and now as of
this past year we're now officially a
sanctuary state I'm super excited about
Stacey Abrams
in Georgia who will be the first black
woman ever to serve as governor in the
entire United States Stacey Abrams wants
to make sure that we dismantle the ways
in which black people are being over
criminalized in Georgia's criminal
justice system the race that I'm mostly
excited for right now is the governor
race in Florida definitely Andrew
Gilliam has been with us from the start
parkland then there's the State
Legislators 2018 is a big year for these
races because 82% of those seats are up
for a vote and state lawmakers are the
people that set your state's agenda on
things like marijuana abortion the
budget or whether or not it's illegal to
throw poop out of a moving car which is
a real law in the state of Oregon for
some reason Illinois where Chicago is
there are really strict gun laws but in
the states around Illinois there are not
strict gun laws so a lot of the guns
that come into Chicago and cause the gun
violence there come from the states
around them with really who really lacks
gun laws so if you can influence your
state legislature to put gun reform laws
in place in your state then you make
your state to save your place and there
are four states around you a safe place
before we go to more local races let's
do one more state-level office that you
probably haven't thought a lot about
State Attorney General 30 of them will
be voted on this November attorneys
general are the top legal officer in
every state often called the people's
lawyer they work on everything from
environmental laws to labor protection
to consumer rights and perhaps most
notably they deal with criminal justice
they get to decide where money goes in
relationship to policing and police but
they also get to determine what is
criminal what is not criminal
but the sentencing guidelines are while
we're on the topic of police reform
let's go more local and go to County
Sheriff
the sheriff oversees what's happening
with police and policing and law
enforcement in your County that's like
really the community that you live in
and how your Sheriff chooses to work
with ice says a lot about whether your
community is resisting or carrying out
deportations so the sanctuary state bill
that was recently passed in California
essentially said that the state was not
going to you
and even state or local resources to
cooperate with ice certain sheriffs
across the state have complained that
this new bill has made their jobs
difficult you kind of have to ask
yourself the question as a voter is do I
want this person representing me and and
do I also want this person leading the
charge and making sure that my community
is safe district attorneys and
prosecutors are next they're the
attorneys that represent the government
and you've probably heard of them in the
context of police brutality specifically
when they choose not to file charges
against officers that shoot people
listen to how Alesia Garza says that she
realized the importance of DA's when she
was protesting police violence we were
arrested and we were charged with issues
related to civil disobedience even
though a district attorney may have been
obscured to us before it became very
clear to us when we were at the mercy of
the district attorney finally let's talk
about in office that you probably didn't
know existed the waterboard you look at
those water board seats people who whose
job is essentially is to bring in water
into the community and how to manage it
a large number of those seats go
uncontested if you're a voter looking to
make the biggest difference possible
both for your local water board person
because water is essentially a human
right there are so many more races like
this that we don't have time to go into
like school board and mayor and judge
and remember you won't be voting on all
of these positions in November because
it depends on where you live so check
your local ballot read up on the
candidates and the issues and remember
don't be a Bart Simpson so when people
say that your vote doesn't matter what I
would tell those people is go talk to
the lord of Sparta
go tell John Lewis these are two civil
rights legends in our community who have
shed their blood sweat and tears just so
that they can go into the voting booth
one day and go for a couple candidates
whether it's governor waterboard sees or
school board hey everyone thanks so much
for watching because facts don't forget
to like share and subscribe for more
videos like this and while you're here
let us know what issues or candidates
have you excited for the midterm
election and what you'll be voting on
let us know in the comments and we'll
see you back here next week